-Hey guys, with summer movie
season here,
there's tons of great stuff
in theaters right now.
So, I wanted to run down
everything worth seeing
in a new segment.
It's time for "The Tonight Show
Hollywood Pop Corner."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hollywood Pop Corner ♪
♪ Hollywood Pop Corner ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're in Hollywood
Pop Corner.
Let's roll picture.
[ Laughter ]
"Lightyear."
You won't need a light beer
to enjoy "Lightyear."
In fact, the only buzz I got
was from actor Chris Evans,
who'll have audiences
in bliss heavens.
Should you see it?
I Holly-would.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Elvis."
He's left the building,
but he's shimmying back into
theaters everywhere.
Austin Butler's performance
had this critic all shook up.
And I, for one,
smell a hunk-a hunk-a
burning up the box office.
Should you see it?
I Holly-would.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"jurassic World: Dominion."
No, not "da minions,"
those little yellow scamps.
But there's plenty of mischief
in this world,
caused by all the bloodthirsty
dinosaurs running amok.
Should man play God?
Probably not.
Should you see it?
I Holly-would.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Top Gun: Maverick."
Tom Cruise may be leaving
on a jet plane,
but it's audiences who'll be
back again and again
to see the sequel
with all the right stuff.
"Top Gun"?
More like top-notch
entertainment.
Permission to be thrilled?
Aye-aye Holly-would.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Bad Guys."
More like "the great
family film."
This movie's filled with heart,
laughs, and style to spare.
To quote another bad guy,
"Duh."
Billy Ei-Holly-would.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Morbius."
♪ Morb, morb, morb ♪
♪ How do you like it,
how do you like it? ♪
I love this tale
of the Dracula doctor
with the heart
of an Oscar goal.
[ Laughter ]
Should you see it?
Your call.
I'm not your boss.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh. [ Laughs ]
Well, the corn...
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
Corn's getting cold,
which means it's time to roll
credits on the Pop Corner.
Remember to silence
your cellphones.
I'll see you at the claw machine
in the lobby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Hollywood Pop Corner ♪
♪ Hollywood Pop Corner ♪